hello everyone and yes the rumors you
heard are true today this channel
reached 500,000 subscribers and I thank
you all for that it's it's a remarkable
milestone and I'm well I'm incredibly
lucky to be able to do what I do and you
know to continue creating chess content
on a daily basis with with so many
people interested so I'm incredibly
grateful for that so I'm incredibly
grateful that people are into chess that
people enjoy just so much and I never
even dreamed of well yeah I remember
when I started even even having I don't
know maybe maybe 10,000 subscribers and
this is half a million of course you all
know that but half a million just sounds
way cooler so that being said we're also
gonna discuss that a bit more and I do
have something planned for Saturday
where a nice stream tournament only
chess and also a nice giveaway but we're
gonna mention that at the end of the
video and also something else but
getting back to this and this is what
you're all interested in it's Michael
towel versus Jack Miller it's a game
from a simultaneous exhibition held in
Chicago in 1988 so a bit of an older
towel but you know it's still still a
very magical towel but his opponent Jack
Miller and that's the only information
we have on mr. Miller there's nothing
else and this is the only game played by
Jack Miller in the database
so as usual we were using the ID image
of the hoodie guy and I'm wearing a
hoodie to honor the hoodie guy and for
this game against all I'm sure you'll
agree that we should definitely honor
the hoodie guy so without further ado
let's check it out tall with the white
pieces opens with E 4 we have E 5 by mr.
Jack Miller will Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and Bishop to c4 tall goes for the
Italian game with Knight to f6 the two
Knights defense by mr. hoodie guy and
now d4 and here the the most often
replied one played even today is just e
captures on d4 but mr. Miller and we
don't have any information on how strong
mr. Miller is or anything place these
six it's it's a bit of an inferior
but okay it's a simultaneous exhibition
you know they are not professionals D
captures on e5 immediately by talent now
Knight captures on e4 problem is if you
play this then you either lose castling
privileges if King captures then also
Bishop captures an f7 if Knight captures
then after you guard the d4 pawn you can
either you're threatening this guy you
can also go for Knight g5 to f7 so it's
not not another great position for black
so here instead Miller goes Knight
captures on e4 and ok with Bishop
captures on f7 by tal just creating some
commotion you know he's gonna win back
this guy with Queen to d5 check it's not
a problem
King captures now comes Queen to d5
check Bishop to e6 blocking and now
Queen captures on e4 just recapturing a
piece Bishop to e7 here Miller wants to
get rook to f18 and get the King to
safety to Castle artificially tall
castles and now d5 and interestingly
this is only move Knight and this
position has never been reached again
after this game was played we have Queen
back to D 3 by tau and Queen to d7
developing connecting rooks
we have rook to e1 and they're now
getting the other rook to f8 it's very
interesting I don't know it seems like
this rook should go to the f8 and then
maybe this should go somewhere else but
okay mr. Miller knows his business
we are Group A to F 8 and now Knight 8c3
start continuous development and now
kinked ie8 he decides that the king is
much safer in the center of the board
we have Knight to g5 by tal Bishop g5 is
also also a possibility
so if captures then you have a very nice
knight on d5 but okay tau plays in a
different style then mostly everyone
else with Bishop to c5 threatening the F
DuPont and here already tall decides to
go for a very interesting idea here top
plays Knight captures on e6 and okay
he'll I was a little check here not a
problem with gush of character son f2
with check King to h1 and now Bishop
captures an e1 winning calls rook and
here top plays Knight captures on f8
although there was a there was an
interesting line here Knight character
Sundy
but it really requires a lot of
calculation because here just both
Knights are attacking the c7 pawn
there's not much you can do about that
so of course you cannot capture because
just Knight captures wins the Queen the
thing is after Knight captures you can
go Bishop to a5 to defend this guy here
and now Tao could go Bishop d2 the try
and or you know overload the bishop but
then you have Knight captures an e5 with
an attack on the Queen Queen to d4 and
now Queen captures on e6 now it's
possible because the bishop is guarding
this spawn but now Bishop captures on e5
and the game continues white will be
better but it's it's a lot of
calculation and it's a simultaneous
exhibition tall has to play on all the
boards so tile goes for the more
straightforward Knight captures on f8 we
look after Sun f8 and now Bishop to g5
still it's not that big of an issue
having back rank issues because the
Queen is guarding f1 so there is no roof
to f1 mate but by playing Bishop to g5
Bishop there is a well tall is
threatening to just recapture the bishop
but better than just moving the bishop
with Bishop f2 or Bishop Catherine c3 is
night the b4 and this is exactly what
Miller plays he says you cannot abandon
your guard of the f1 square otherwise
you're gonna get made it so we have
Queen back to e 2 and now another strike
by Miller Knight captures and c2 so the
rook is under attack and still you
cannot capture the night because of rook
to f1 mate so what can you do here the
thing is okay you could go for route
captures anyone it's probably it's the
engine stop recommendation but tall tall
very rarely cares what the engine thinks
because here after captures captures and
captures the problem is black has Queen
to f5 with a double attack the bishop is
under attacked and also Queen to f1
would result in mate so here H 4 is the
only move that prevents both threats but
now after this trade captures captures
with check King H 2 and now d4 black
will get an excellent game even though
he's a rook against a knight and a
bishop but they are a for the moment not
very coordinated 94 h 6 and so on
and this will be a very strong pawn so
it all doesn't like his chances here so
after Knight captures and c2 tall
doesn't go for the for this route
captors anyone which probably everyone
would do first he goes east six and okay
the queen is under attack and here he he
needs to work his magic he needs his
opponent to give him at least something
because obviously this Jack Miller is no
wood pusher you know and here
Queen to c6 is the way to go it seems
like an odd square because well it just
feels disconnected from the game so Jack
Miller played Queen to d6 but Queen to
d6 gives Stahl a very important tempo
and Queen to d6 okay it makes much more
sense you have ideas like Queen to e5
offering a queen for rook to f1 mate
there are a lot of ideas here but you
also give tile an incredibly important
tempo and that is night the b5 this is
what Tull plays and now you have
problems here Queen to e5 Miller plays
this but now it's a it's it's a
classical Queen stand off White Queen
cannot capture the black Queen because
of rook to f1 mate and the black Queen
cannot capture the White Queen because
of Knight to c7 mate because here as you
can see the pawn and the bishop control
all of the squares around the black ink
so if the Queen moves from guarding the
c7 pawn Knight captures on c7 is made so
here's a very rare situation in chess
where there are two queens in the center
of the board you know just eyeing each
other and you know me and neither is
allowed to capture the other one so here
tau goes for the move the only move that
allows him to continue this and it's
it's an incredibly strong attacking move
h4 just guarding the bishop here
creating in a square root square for the
king and also creating a very strong
threat just of Queen captures Queen
because now it will be possible there is
no rook to f1 mate
so here Miller plays Queen to g3 Miller
has to keep an eye on the c7 pawn and
now comes another incredibly strong move
from tall and it's it's hard to even
find such a strong move
I could even let you pause the video and
try to figure out which strong
this is well well I'll give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who found
that congratulations you are you're just
a natural-born attacker that's just just
an amazing move and for those of you
just want to enjoy the show it's rook to
d1 rook to d1 the main threat rook
captures and d5 followed by rook to d8
mate so of course you want to get the
other guy into the into the game as well
the problem is if you just defend with
c6 then rook to d3 traps the Queen well
almost
the Queen has no squares other than b8
but if you go to b8 with the Queen then
just rook to f3 and now black has no
moves you will either get captures and
then Queen f3 check and get the Queen to
f7 or a black capture screen captures
and now there's no defense against Queen
to f7 this will be just the this will
just end in mate just you know check and
mate so this is not possible after rook
to d1 incredibly strong move by table
but Miller replies with an equally
strong move he plays rook the f2 he says
I don't really care about your mate in
two because I'm threatening mate in one
Queen captures and g2 is just made so
how can stop how can tell prevent this
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find the winning idea for tal
here in this situation so for those of
you who are able to do it of course as
it style you you obviously gets the move
and tell is very proud of you
for finding such a move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen captures an f2 just giving up the
Queen for those who found Knight
captures on c7 it it does give white an
edge but black is able to organize a
defense because after Queen captures
here and Queen to b5 check yes you have
to block and then now rook captures on
d5 I'm sure y'all saw this if Queen
captures Queen then rook to d8 is made
but the black is able to organize the
defense would rook to f6 this is the
problem with night the King Knight
captures on c7 line
so after loop to have to towel just
played Queen captures here and now what
do you play here if Queen captures Queen
then it's just game over after Knight
captures on c7 your own movies King f8
now a7 check you have to go King g8
and now you just bring your queen into
the game okay Queen f8 blocks not just
25 and at the end of the day you are up
a whole rook of course it's a completely
winning game for white so after Queen
captures an F - of course Miller did not
play Queen K at rest he said okay I'm
gonna play Bishop characters and now my
queen is still guarding the c7 pawn but
now tile finally gets his rook captures
on d5 which is the whole point of the
game and now how do you prevent rook the
rook to b8 mate you just don't there's
no stopping this still all of these
squares around the black King are
covered yeah you can go to a fade but
it's of little little importance because
the rook to d8 will still be made and
here Miller can easily resign but he
says nope
I have Queen captures on h4 check which
just gives up the Queen we have the shop
characters and the blush of characters
on h4 so now it's a knight and rook
against the bishop and night so here
towel is just up the exchange with a
very strong past ecigs pawn and tal
makes quick work of the position Knight
captures on c7 with check King to f8 and
now rope to f5 check here tal wants to
get after the King moves
rook to f7 followed by e 7 which is just
winning so of course the Miller block
block this but now rope the d5 with a
similar idea at all once rug d7 Luke f7
and East 7 and that's that's all there
is with a 5 by Miller noggins rug d7
this cannot be prevented nice to be four
and rook to f7 check we have King to g8
and here talk and choose between two two
very strong moves he can either just
push push east 7 and that's that's just
it if King captures rook then you
promote to a queen that's mate and the
other one and the other one is the one
tall chose the one CEO maybe more
aesthetically pleasing
route cat person f6 just a living
eliminating the defender so you cannot
even sacrifice a piece for the e7 pawn
and here if you capture a 7 just the
point is coming to te 8 with and the
knight is covering the square so a game
over the knight cannot reach the 8
square you know the Knights do far away
so Miller play Knight to c6 we're
to f7 finally we have g6 and now East
seven Bend now there's just nothing more
to do here because after King captures
you get he ate with the Queen so after
this East seventh move Miller resigned
the game and another wonderful victory
by Michael tall in a simultaneous
exhibition held in Chicago in 1988 there
is a very little well there's basically
no information on this event so if any
of you have any access to this event or
the more information about the whole
simultaneous exhibition that took place
do share in the comments and I will pin
it so everyone else can can also learn a
bit more about it and also a lot of you
may think but if you know everyone knows
that Michael Tao is is the you know
Guardian basically of this channel you
know we all will love the great Nisha
and the reason why we don't show more of
his games is because I don't know how
long I will be doing YouTube you know we
don't want to run out of tall games too
soon you know yeah we can always just
show more but if we show them all then
we can show any more tall games that's
just the way the way it is so that's why
after doing the 1959 candidates and well
some of his more and more famous games
and his match against the between akin
1960
we basically put a stop to all games and
then we're just showing at all game now
and then but we will we will show more
and no worries we still have the chorus
all candidates we have the rematch with
Botvinnik we we have a lot of very
interesting games from from tall and we
will show them so no worries and yeah
that's the game and regarding the
celebration of the 500 thousand
subscribers milestone we will have a
nice tournament on leaches it will be
held on Saturday and most likely I'm not
sure because there's also a chess titled
arena and Saturday but I can't have any
other day so I will have to do it on the
same day as the leisure style arena of
course not not in the same time
delicious title arena is I believe from
from 7 to 9 p.m. Central European Time
and we will probably be having a
tournament to two hours before that so
maybe five to seven central Europe
and time p.m. and then me and then well
you know play some games as we usually
do have some have a nice giveaway the
giveaway will be as usual as it always
is to attend 10 Amazon gift cards so you
can you know buy yourself a book or or
about Bobby Fischer action figure as as
you guys usually do so more about that
in some of the videos that will you know
come after this one and in in the week
to come but definitely it will be held
on Saturdays so if you don't mind you
know free free or Saturday evening you
know grab some beer or some or some tea
or some coffee and we're gonna have a
nice nice tournament and in the nice
hangout so that's that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it really an amazing
performance by both tall and Miller and
I'm very sorry I can't find any more
information on mr. Miller because it you
know he obviously plays some very
exciting chess he he had talked on the
ropes at some point but now just you
know worked his magic and in the end
this is the end result so I would like
to thank Scott sonam born they're good
in such a rich Madson Esther Nielsen a
marsh MIT and the James done for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
Scott's on important asked if if Stephen
Hawking has some documented chess games
I don't know if any if I did it would be
very interesting but unfortunately I
don't if any of you have access to some
games played by Stephen Hawking you know
do sure I would also enjoy enjoy those
games so yeah also wanted to mention
something else but can't can't really
remember I will maybe remember in in the
next video but yeah that's it I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous video Sarah thank all for
watching and I will see you soon are
continuing the coverage of the fee
diagram pre continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and you know
working up to that next milestone the
next 500 thousands but you know maybe in
a few years we'll see how it goes
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day